[Music]
let's play e4
oh it's a rematch okay okay guys i'll
play the king's gambit
a lot of people have been requesting
this i will play a king's gambit
i don't know it very well i've never
played the king's gamut as my full-time
opening
of course i know a good amount but
but don't expect uh like top line theory
thank you
chupacabras ucsd okay
so first of all the first misconception
about the king's gambit is that white
plays d4 white does not play d4
uh and the reason the d4 immediately is
a bad move is that
black has a super nasty check on h4 that
actually forces white's king out because
you can't play g3 due to f takes g3 so
you actually have to develop your knight
first
well you don't have to that's not the
only move but it's considered the most
reputable
because you stopped quinn h4 now there
are several possibilities now it's time
to go d4
and d6 is possible so now we're
threatening to win back the pawn if
black allows us yeah so g5 is the move
black clings to the pawn and these pawns
can potentially combine
to storm white's king side and i will
play if he does play g4 i'm gonna play a
really interesting gambit
now we need to develop our pieces fast
one of the rules for gambits
so h4 i think is a move but let's play
this in more romantic style
um one of the sort of bottom of h4 is
apparently the theoretical move but i'm
going to
play a variation of the movie i'm just
going to develop my bishop one of the
rules for playing gambits
is that you need to develop fast and you
need to develop actively and
you should never be afraid to sacrifice
more material
that's what makes gambits fun if you
sacrifice a pawn that means
you've almost made this contract right
where okay
i'm going for the initiative you can't
be stingy
with the rest of your material that
would be kind of hypocritical if you're
playing a gambit
so we're gonna play bishop c4 um
and that bishop aims itself at the pawn
we now have two pieces developed and
black is zero
a lot of you guys are also noticing the
move h4 which is a very typical move in
general it undermines the pawn chain
we're going after the base of the pawn
chain
we're trying to soften up that f4 punch
so that's in our pocket
let's see what will does and we might
play this move
against certain responses or we might
just continue our development by
castling
okay
well yeah okay bishop b6 now that move
is
i'm not familiar with it and i think i
know why it's inaccurate so
uh we need to of course decide whether
we trade now one
i want you know if you play gambits then
listen up because this is important
when some when people play gambits a
common type of mistake that i
see is that they will
they will become completely allergic to
any kind of trades
there will be this thought that if you
play a gambit that means every single
trade by definition is good for your
opponent
so they will avoid every trade they'll
go like d5 in this position or they'll
move the bishop back
now that is not quite true it might be
the case that a queen trade is bad but
that doesn't mean a single minor piece
trade
is going to somehow cause the gambit to
lose its potency in fact
now that is the opposite here if we take
the bishop
black has to take with a pawn and that
really weakens that king it opens up
this diagonal
and uh we're absolutely going to do that
if we can follow up correctly this is
going to be squarely in white's favor
thank you jts returns
so what move should we now play this is
a move i've already referenced
so you guys should now see that it is
very very strong
what else should we notice about this
the pawn on e6 is undefended
it's undefended which means that we can
basically set up a fork here or a double
attack
the move is h4 if g4 then knight to g5
and in contrast to the previous instance
the knight is also
attacking e6 so we are attacking two of
black's pawns
three of black spawns f4 g4 and e6
black's position basically falls apart
right off the bat
bishop h6 is an understandable move but
still black is not holding this together
very well
okay now we have a cool idea um the
obvious move is h takes g5 which breaks
up black spawn chain it forces the
bishop on an awkward square
that is not i believe the best idea who
can spot a
cool little alternative yes we can go
knights hg5
and if bishop takes g5 we have an
intermediate move queen h5 how do i see
this well
as i pointed out if you've noticed that
the diagonal has been weakened
then you should be automatically
searching for ways to get the knight off
of f3 in a good way
and then put the queen on h5 this should
not be like oh my god i didn't realize
this was a thing
uh you should absolutely realize that
it's a thing after black plays fv
okay so queen h5 track forces the king
out
then we win back the bishop okay king f8
is probably not
great because king d7 king c8 may be
evacuating the king was better although
that's still bad
now f4 is hanging at the f file will
become
will open up and that'll be a disaster
no this is just
very very bad for will uh if we play
accurately i think white should be
close to winning here uh so we have a
couple of moves
on tap here first of all g6 yeah g6
seems very very strong
um potentially because it attacks h7
and uh he's played e5 so how should we
play this
what we can try to do here we can take
on e so first of all let's take on e5
uh because opening up the position is
clearly in our favor
um it's clearly in our favor and also it
softens up the e5 but now after he takes
back
that pawn is going to be undefended now
i think we have a really nice move
which i just mentioned what am i talking
about here
so the move is
drum roll please g6 okay
so it does a couple of things it it it
opens up the attack on e5 it attacks h7
and uh we further soften up his king
side now there were alternatives we we
could have gone
simply knight c3 we could have maybe put
the bishop on a3
but how can i resist such a move how can
i resist such a tempting move thank you
mick
uh analiche appreciate the two months
and uh black can defend here i think
will can can maybe survive
if he plays very accurately but such
positions are are very very hard to to
defend
so this is yeah that's why the king's
gambit is is such a fun opening
when it goes well you can play some
really nice attacking games
in in the king's gambit and if black
doesn't know how to respond
then it's it's also very hard to play
off the cuff
can't he take your broken attacker king
well he can't i mean maybe you mean
take here but then the rook drops on h8
it's undefended
um yeah it's it's not quite gg
yet i i think i see a good move for
black
uh but i'm not actually sure what
exactly black can do to defend
because we're attacking so many things
at once
and i was hoping he would play something
like this because we have a really
really pretty move
now a lot of people would grab on h7
immediately but that's less good than it
seems
because he can just move the night out
but as a lot of you guys are already
pointing out
when there is a pawn on g6 at least with
two percent of your brain you should be
thinking
man i'm pretty close to promoting this
pawn i'm pretty darn close to promoting
the spawn now first of all queen f5
check
he doesn't have to go to king g7 he can
cover that check with queen f6
we're pretty close to promoting the pawn
what's stopping the pawn from promoting
is only the rook on h8 right that's the
only thing
that's not allowing the spawn to promote
what we can actually do
is sacrifice the queen on h7 and this is
more of a common idea than i think some
people may realize
this basically either wins the rook or
it forces the rook to take the queen in
which case we take with the pawn
and promotion is unstoppable we will not
we will not be trying to take the knight
we will be trying to promote nha that's
a damn girl
damn girl kind of move it's cool but at
the same time it results
from the fact that black is so poorly
developed here that he doesn't have the
resources
to stop the pawn even in a middle game
and as will is thinking i don't want to
waste any time so i will see if i can
look up a game where i
first i remember this clearly who was
playing in this game
it was the game in which i saw this
technique applied
let me see if i can spot this game
yeah chimpanzee you were the first uh
you were the first person to spot this i
think okay
so one second please i'm looking
to see if i can find this right
so he takes that we're gonna take here
yeah it's not this game
i mean i can find other other instances
of this
thank you uh swagmas prime
i'm going to do a little a little bit of
a search okay so being deformed
that is a very good move thank you prank
prank t
and uh you will see that this often
happens after we win material we have to
actually defend now
we have to defend and we have to defend
very accurately because
we have given up our queen which means
our our homeland
is under assault here which which means
that we need to be super precise in how
we defend this
okay so uh the obvious move is to
promote the pot
the obvious move is to promote the pawn
but first of all let it be known let the
record reflect we don't need to rush
he actually still can't stop us from
promoting
so it might be worthwhile investing a
tempo
to defend the pawn on e4 before we
promote let me think about
this for a second yes there is actually
a super interesting line there so let's
go knight c3 you guys are awesome seeing
this
right off the bat remember that he he
can't castle his king has already moved
and um let's see well let's let's see
what he um
what he comes up with here the thing is
if he plays rook to d8
he actually isn't threatening a check on
d1 he's not threatening anything
our pieces may look passive but they are
controlling all of the important squares
it's important not to panic in these
situations uh and
it's also important to realize when
you're not in a hurry sometimes you can
afford
a move like this so anyways
okay so i'm i'm looking up some games
by the way in in this line okay i see a
nice one
okay i have a game prepared for you guys
to really hammer this this idea home
because it occurs in many different
openings
okay knight before i saw this that is
what i was calculating
will by the way playing super well i
have to give him a lot of kudos for the
way he's defending this
here's the thing he's attacking c2 and
it seems tempting to panic because we
can't defend it we actually cannot
defend that
but we don't need to because here's the
thing we can promote
and after he takes on c2 king e2
and he takes the rook it is finally our
turn to attack
and his king is basically now at the
mercy
of our queen and our rook so what move
are we going to have at the end of that
line to
essentially start an insurmountable
attack because his species are scattered
all over the world the rook is not
deployed
uh so that rook on a1 will sacrifice
itself for the greater good
the move is no queen h6 well rock h6 is
fine but even simpler is to play rook to
h7
in order to threaten queen g7 i don't
think that can be stopped
i don't think that can be stopped maybe
will shouldn't take on c2 i mean that
would be really
impressive if he does that does
something like rook d8 here that would
probably be the best defense
uh because rook h7 right here doesn't
work due to queen g1 check we need to be
careful
i don't think it's perpetual i mean
because if he takes on c2 and goes
uh and goes knight a1 rook h7 he can
give us one
check on c4 but we can pretty easily i
think sidestep that
via via h2 well if the knight doesn't
take the rook i don't see the perpetual
i i mean maybe he'll i don't see the
perpetual king can always run
run this way if necessary but i don't
think that'll be necessary
yeah i don't think that's necessary
but let's see what will comes up with
okay so he takes beth harmon thank you
for the prime
oh we have several good moves here if we
think very deeply we can actually see
that the queens
are in a standoff so in addition to rook
h7 we actually can play bishop takes f4
and then deploy our bishop to h6 so that
also
is i think pretty darn devastating
um but let me just verify that there's
no perpetual
so rook h7 c4 kmh1 queen d4
king of one queen d3 king g1 24 king h2
okay
there's no perpetual rock h7
or k7 and there's just no way to stop
all of these
all of these threats he can maybe
prolong the game
if he if he gives up the queen but
that's the best that black can do this
knight is out of the game that's
important
so this bishop on c1 again is the unsung
hero of this position it is controlling
the e3 square
is controlling the e3 square which means
the queen cannot deliver a check there
that is important
thank you beth you too
keep it up in season two kings gambit
man
that is the uh the apartment kind of
opening
gotta say gotta say and the history of
the king's gamba will be
even more interesting perhaps to you
guys
no i don't know i'm i'm just hinting
that season two would be nice
okay so he gives us a check and now we
zigzag our way out of the checks
okay f2 uh thank you uh
docodoc holiday dds
queen d4 and we zigzag our way to g1 and
then if necessary to h2
that is another very good technique by
the way when you are trying to escape
the checks a lot of people get
overwhelmed
but what you need to do is you need to
find a target square or a target area of
the board
to escape to so the way that i see this
is i'm like okay
where do i want the king to end up and i
see i can go to h2 i can see cover
behind the g2 pawn it's easier if you
already have a square in mind and now
all you need to do
is you need to chart a course to that
square queen d1 checked is not possible
then i guard
that and i have several good uh
illustrative examples in queen end games
you actually can apply that concept
with particular effectiveness you
sometimes have to apply that concept
and i'll show you guys a very good
illustrative game in that regard as well
and that's exactly what we do we go king
g1
and then if he gives us a check on d4 we
can go to h1 or h2
i think there's plenty of meat uh for
season two i think there there's
absolutely plenty
world championship oh and will finds a
nice defensive move
queen g3 i actually didn't see that
that's beautiful okay
which means we still have some work to
do guys um
okay so let's unpack unpack this move
for a second
the idea behind queen g3 is first of all
he is threatening a perpetual
second of all he defends the g7 square
so we need to make a move that deals
with both at the same time we need to
deal with the screen we need to try to
get that queen out of there
and we need to stop the perpetual now
when we stop a perpetual we can stop it
from either
end we do not have to defend this square
we can also defend this square and we
actually can do that with tempo
we can defend the g3 square no no no no
where are you guys going don't get the
rook
back to h3 hey this knight it needs a
job
it's it's i want to be involved yeah
let's make the knight involved
we don't want to get the rook out the
rook is a key attacker if we go rook h3
then he goes queen g7
and the attack evaporates so 92 is a key
move
attacks the queen the queen has to stay
on the g file and now we're going to use
our minor pieces
to tip the scales in our favor the rook
and the queen are keeping black down
keeping black paralyzed
it's the knight in the bishop that are
going to be
the ultimate finishers of the attack
they're going to be the pieces that
overextend black
because black's queen is simply wearing
too many hats and has to protect
too many squares we're gonna sack
something on f4 and open the floodgates
thank you amen i mean
for the pride
okay yes a perpetual is a series of
checks until the game ends in repetition
because you cannot
evade the checks ultimately perpetual
check results
in three time repetition like if you
don't accept the draw
that's the point okay
so hopefully this move makes sense guys
and um okay so now we have a very pretty
win
so you guys should all see that
the bishop now pins the queen so a
sacrifice on f4
is quite now
the rationale behind it is that as soon
as black takes his eyes off of the g7
square
this will be checkmate not immediately
but the king will move and we will take
the knight etc
so we need to find a way to get this
queen out of g5
and the only pieces that we have left
that are not fulfilling
vital duties are the uh
are the the bishop and the knight so we
need to figure out what we want to
sacrifice
on f4 what do we want to sacrifice
enough for the bishop or the knight
i actually think both moves are fine but
i do think there is a more accurate way
of doing this we
so why do you guys want to sack the
bishop have you thought about
sacrificing both so let's compare let's
compare
bishop takes f4 e takes f4 knight takes
f4 has the benefit of threatening a fork
on e6
but black can stop that fork by getting
his rook to e8
now let's look at the other option
knight takes f4 ef4 bishop f4
well that attacks the queen directly the
queen has to stick on the g file
and once the queen moves away from the g
file a little bit of visualization
practice for you guys
what move are we gonna have to finish
off the attack in that final position
that bishop on f4
bishops are generally great attackers
bishop h6
of course beth harmon finds it she sees
everything
is going to be absolutely crushing it's
going to force black to give away the
game this is actually a really nice game
i'm glad will will is defending as well
as he is because this is really helping
us showcase
some key attacking techniques so he
takes f4 bishop takes f4
sacking the pieces on one square i
always like that
okay
well we can alicia the rook will defend
the e6 square
yeah this is a beth harmon style game
for sure he takes f4 bishop takes f4
again if queen takes f4 then queen g7 he
can give a check on c5
okay queen g7 and uh now
we still have to be careful do not put
the queen on e7 that would be a bow test
gambit that would not be checkmate
um so what is the fastest checkmate what
should we do it's a little bit of
another zigzag method uh another kind of
pretty little sequence
but very simple right we want to
take the knight queen f8 and then that
queen's gonna maneuver to migrate to e6
and then to d7 to deliver the checkmate
don't pre-move this move he might go
queen e7
but the game is over um yes queen e6
and uh guess what let's check mate like
this you know let's let's check made in
style rook hey
the queen is pinned checkmating without
taking the queen good game well that was
fantastic defense
uh it takes two to play a nice game and
will you certainly played
extremely uh you put your heart into it
i could tell so
nicely done awesome and we have a lot to
analyze too
lots of cool details in this game okay
so our king's gambit experiment uh
turned out pretty darn well now
the king's gambit has been around since
the 16th century
king's gamut has been around essentially
forever okay literally as long as
chess in europe has been around so is
the king's gambit the first recorded
game played in the king's game it was by
ray lopez
so ry lopez did not only play the rail
lopez he played
in 1560 in rome an italian player named
giovanni dakutri leonardo
not leonardo da vinci uh although
leonardo da vinci probably played
maybe played chess i don't know um but
he played a guy named
the chew tree i think it's pronounced c
in italian
that shoe tree and ry lopez absolutely
demolished him in a queen's gambit
uh the game between ray lopez and the
chew tree continued as follows
black in the game played d6 that's like
an old-fashioned move declining the
declining the king's gambit it's not a
great move
um because it's really really passive ry
lopez played bishop c4
c6 and knight f3 bishop g4 and
black is already in big trouble f takes
e5 d takes e5 and
what very typical tactical move did
white now play
um you can see that uh rye lopez was
quite good actually he wrote a book on
chess but
leonardo da chuchi was just not not a
very good player bishop f7
95 i think we'll forgive him he lived in
the 1500s
queen takes g4 and now queen e6
white to play and win the game in the
fastest way rye lopez played a perfect
game i think he was cheating
i i think i think uh ry lopez might have
been cheating guys to be honest
he might have been using uh socks
stockfish uh 0.0001
queen ca queen d8 queen takes d8 king
takes d and knight f7 knight takes a
train
um so he he's notorious he got banned
yeah
he he absolutely got banned so
he was using houdini exactly so that's
the game between ray lopez and leonardo
that was the first ever
recorded game featuring the king's
gambit uh what's impressive
about this by the way is that f4 is not
an intuitive move
let's get something very straight the
intuitive move here is knight f3 f4
actually like weakens white's king
it took some cojones to play a move like
this
and uh the fact that a lot of these
early players were willing to do that
is is squarely to their credit uh we
shouldn't take that for granted then it
was played in 1590
by an italian player named giulio
polario
and palario also crushed
his opponent a guy named busnardo and
then
the famous geokino graco
a player who i've mentioned several
times he was an italian living in the
early 17th century in the 1600s
and he actually formalized some of the
analysis of the king's gambit
uh he did a lot of work on it and then
the king's gambit was wildly popular as
you guys know morphe's day in the 1800s
everybody was playing it it was all the
rage
it was for a time more popular than any
other opening
and then slowly but surely italian rye
lopez
the scotch all of those openings started
becoming more popular king's game it
really fell out of favor
probably in the first half of the 1900s
people started realizing that black had
many ways to play against it
and if black was very precise then white
would be the one struggling for equality
and then when computers came around uh
what should be pointed out the king's
gambit has
not i repeat it has not been refuted
black is not winning
uh black does not have a big advantage
but i believe that black has several
ways to get let's just say a very
comfortable position and more
importantly
black has several ways to take the sting
out of the king's gambit
if if white still got an attacking
position people would be okay with it
but black has ways to play against it
that really takes the fun out of it
that's that's what that's the reason it
fell out of favor
okay so finally hope you guys enjoyed
that little history he takes up four
knight f3
um d6 is one of the
possible moves here for sure let me
check on its popularity
so d6 is the second most popular move
and now i played d4
and g5 of course you have to keep the
pawn otherwise this doesn't make any
sense
and the move bishop c4 is actually rare
yes you guys are correct
h4 is the main line here h4 and this
is actually a sacrifice line h4 g4
knight g5
and you might look at this and say well
wait a second actually no knight g1
knight g1
knight g5 is possible mauro zevich
played knight g5 knight g5 is
interesting but probably unsound
uh but the move is actually knight back
to g1 the whole point is that you've
softened up the f4 pawn to such a degree
that you can undevelop your knight if
you take this pawn then it all is
justified in the end
but i was out of book i decided to play
a pretty natural move bishop c4
and according to the computer um no
there's nothing particularly wrong with
this move now if black had played g4
i fully intended to sacrifice the knight
in castle
and this is a kind of a variety of
what's called mutzio's gambit
i think the actual muzio gambit is in a
slightly different
version but the spirit of the gambit is
kept sound
because you can see how many pieces
white has developed
and how weak black's king is i think
from a practical perspective
if black doesn't know the theory this is
very hard to play against
okay so the mutil gambit was what i
intended but bishop e6 is the first i
think serious mistake
takes an h4 so i don't know what black
should have done here i mean if you go
g4 then this is just a disaster i think
bishop h6
is not terrible maybe g takes h4 is the
lesser evil
and then try to plug this diagonal
somehow
but but let's fast forward to the
interesting bit so h6 g5 e5
d takes c5 why was this move necessary
because if we go g6 immediately then
then
queen takes e5 is not a threat so we
take him we go g6
and here i think queen f6 was the best
move
i think queen f6 was the best move and
the reason is because queen takes h7
does not work anymore
why is this not winning for white what
nice
defensive resource does black now have
okay now scholars mate does not appear
at high levels
yes knight h6 is one option uh a
slightly inferior option is also to put
the queen behind the pawn here you at
least give up a knight but knight h6
very nice
that is the best move because you also
keep your knight and then you can come
around and take the bottom of the king
okay so knight c6 and now queen takes h7
this is a very typical
as i explained technique in many types
of positions
uh more so than you guys might might
realize
um across a wide variety of of of
openings
and i i pulled up one nice game to show
you one little game segment to
just very quickly demonstrate that
so a game from 1996 hendrix is a is an i
am and in this position in a night or
a completely different opening but a
very similar concept
white to play and crush
very nice move in this position that
white ended up playing
and it's uh you know yeah g6 is right so
g6 is a
is a very pretty move if f takes g6 then
you drop this bond and that's a disaster
in relation to black's king
you cannot play hg6 because the rook is
hanging so black plays f5
and now of course you guys should all
see the move
mad max 4551 thanks for the 3am hype
tier 1 black to play and win
and queen takes h7 and black resigned
amazing huge block just
literally loses the rook you can't leave
it on h8 and
uh here the game is over the single pawn
unstoppable by all of black's pieces all
of which are on the queen side
and black resigned in this position so
you can see that it's uh
yeah this guy got cheesed by queen takes
h7
and this is one of thousands of games in
which
this concept was applied but hopefully
it brings it to life a little bit
and so we do the same thing here queen
h7 gh7 but now will
i have to compliment you you found a lot
of really good moves queen d4 is the
best option
now knight c3 knight c3 defends the pawn
and now knight before ha queen
and what what really curses black is the
fact that none of these squares are
accessible like black just cannot
get his pieces to any important squares
i'm somehow just like defending
everything and
and that's kind of bad luck because i'm
pretty undeveloped uh but it just so
happens
that uh that the pieces are defended
thank you nitrous for the prime of the
five months
and so k2 91 is the best you can do and
now we're okay seven
and here i honestly thought the game was
over i did not see
this move this move queen g3 is very
very strong right it defends g7 and it
threatens perpetual
so 92 is the key move i think without
knight e2
it will not be easy to win now 92
and now knight takes f4 so just to recap
if bishop takes f4
then um then rookie yay and i think
white is still winning but it's not that
simple
it's not that simple but knight f4 is
absolutely crushing
because because of bishop h6
and then queen e5 with uh with checkmate
and just a couple
uh just a couple moves queen c7 and
queen d7 is elementary
my dear watson and so queen takes f4 is
basically forced
uh queen g7 and uh and of course
queen takes she a queen e6 and queen e7
so that was a really nice game
um probably pretty high accuracy
and uh and again it takes two to tango
so that was a fantastic
defensive effort by will forget this to
recap i think
bishop e6 was was a big mistake number
one this this really made it hard to
defend
and maybe in this position i think after
g takes h4
you can more or less survive and then
finally i would say queen f6 in this
position would force g takes h7
sorry in in this position would force g
takes h7 although in a position
like this uh because of this very
monstrous pawn
i mean black is in is in very very big
trouble so
i think that this is um
yeah i i i just don't think this is good
at all okay
so any questions about this game could
you explain your other move
where you could have used the bishop
instead of doing h7
well um yeah sure so
i'm not sure where you mean oh rook h7
okay so i could have done
this bishop takes f4 was also possible i
believe
um because if e takes f4 then the queens
are at a standoff but the reason i
rejected this black is this check on c4
and then he actually can take the bishop
this is still winning
with something like this but i'm pretty
sure that my
my my option was was a little bit
crisper so let me check were there any
big mistakes in this game from my end
i'm just checking really quickly
thanks again everybody for the for the
tremendous support
um as as i check i just wanted to say
once again
uh how much i appreciate everybody being
engaged and those people who
sub and and support me so selflessly are
are you know never taken for granted and
i
keeps me going and i really appreciate
it thank you guys
this was a really nice game